sorti des soins intensifs depuis une
quinzaine de jours boris johnson est
désormais totalement remis de son
infection kovy 19
le premier ministre britannique a donc
repris la main sur les affaires du
royaume uni et fait sa première
déclaration à la presse ce lundi que
maureen je veux m'adresser aux acteurs
économiques aux entrepreneurs à tout ce
dont notre économie dépend
evry - vim
je comprends votre impatience je sais
que sans une impulsion un vrai sens il
n'y aura plus l'économie d'un autre pays
votre urgence et celle du gouvernement
nous devons reconnaître le risque d'une
seconde vague le risque le risque de
perdre le contrôle face à ce virus
les nuls ce ne sera pas une nouvelle
vague de morts mais aussi un désastre
économique
seul hic humant m'excuseras
boris johnson fait face à une pression
grandissante pour dévoiler son plan de
déconfinement le leader conservateur de
55 ans doit également affronter les
critiques pour sa gestion de la crise
sanitaire
un schéma se dessine ici nous avons été
lents à entrer en confinement lent sur
les dépistages lent à mettre en place
des équipements de protection même à ce
moment là à accepter des offres dinan
britannique
le premier secrétaire affirme qu'il ya
une capacité de 40 minutes est par jour
cela signifie qu'avant tierces à 48
tests auraient pu être effectuées mais
que seuls 18 mille ont été réalisés
critiques de l'opposition mais aussi
division en coulisses au sein même de
l'équipe au pouvoir selon la presse
britannique certains poids lourds
s'inquiètent des conséquences sociales
mais aussi sanitaire d'un confinement
trop strictes sur la longueur boris
johnson va donc devoir trancher avec une
équation délicate à résoudre comment
faire redémarrer l'économie au royaume
uni sans risquer un deuxième pic de la
pandémie